et s'ils sont pas fissuré hamidou leur
entre autres à un mode les gens sont
achetés 5000 6000 ouattara tri
en france
ac world élite besoin de gilles moreaux
alors voilà c'est vrai que cette vidéo a
fait énormément parler vous êtes allés
devant le stade de france vous n'aviez
pas de billets pro vous êtes dit je vais
pouvoir rentrer
bonjour
durandet j'ai par teva retour
côté le stade après je vois les anglais
étaient là bateaux sont pas rentrés
qu'on ait commencé le match est commencé
pour site où tout le monde est pour moi
j'ai rentré avec au jeu rentrer par la
porte c'est pas satellite ou par la
rentrée tranquille personne n'a rien
demandé à personne de porter tout est
entré sans rien si je rentrais sont bien
comme ta rentrée toit en bon moi j'ai
rentré var jc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
blague à part blague à part c'est un
jeune de saint denis mais il est assez
des nippes depuis six ans sans histoire
et travail il est coiffeur il est très
attentif et par nombre de personnes qui
vivent dans des quartiers populaires de
la ville de saint denis ce problème
s'est vu qu'il comporte plus de 120000
personnes savoir que cette ville
accueille la finale de la ligue des
champions c'était un événement donc par
curiosité les parties aux abords des
sites et des rentrées
non mais bague à part c'est qu'il y
avait les la fan zone où il y avait les
supporteurs de liverpool et mu altran
supporters de l'état de l'art là c'était
l'heure de rentrer dans le stade il ya
une couille et a eu des supporters faut
dire qu'elle est de liverpool ont poussé
et avait plus de sécurité y avait pas de
policier qui l'a atteint qu'après six
ans après c'est non on comprend en effet
que sa
vidéo pourquoi
la vidéo ici c'est kolontar et
pourquoi tu as fait la vidéo suivi la
vidéo pour mes amis tôt mais on rigolait
avec mes amis d après moi je savais pas
il ya
le stade de france c'est ça j'ai trompé
j'ai mis sur les roses et sociaux c'est
tout après quand je rentre et je parle
de papier les papes et je parle pour le
t4 j'ai pas tkt gers est rentré d'accord
et
si vous vous approchez ce qu'ils sont
venus alors béatrice titres y compris
l'achat contre alors j'aime pas les
lynchages quel qu'il soit ce soit il ya
une justice et donc les lynchages n'ont
jamais lieu d'être sauf que là monsieur
déjà ma première réflexion va vers
monsieur adama on avait déjà eu une
conversation la dernière fois et vous
m'aviez dit oui mais dans les quartiers
ya plein de d'action positive et sa gt
100% d'accord avec vous qu'il fallait
les soutenir aujourd'hui vous soutenez
quelqu'un qui a dit je nique la france
ou je sais pas quoi alors que
apparemment ce monsieur vie en france la
france l'a toujours l'accueil ils
travaillent ici donc en fait cette
personne insultes chacun d'entre nous
vous aussi et donc ses domiciles en plus
il a volé sa place à un supporters qui a
acheté sa place
si la resquille et et qu'il a pris une
place alors qu'ils n'avaient pas de
billets ça revient alors au fait qu'il
ait volé une place à temps
après je la veux je veux passer quelque
chose j'ai son âge demain je peux
rentrer une place sera donc je suis un
gamin j'y vais la cohue c'est
un autre sujet c'est quelqu'un qui
aurait pu rentrer ça mouvement de foule
on y serait allé c'était des gamins ça
c'est avec ce
qui est très grave en revanche c'est
derrière c gepa de papier machin je vais
[ __ ] la france thor injuste dit je
suis là j'ai changé je regarde le match
et tout ça on se serait dit bon bah il
est il a eu sa place à gamaches je vais
[ __ ] la france n'est pas venu dire
derrière le côté pardon je sais pas ce
que je voulais dire j'ai confondu le
stade de france je vais [ __ ] la france
qu'est ce que ça veut dire cette
clinique et clinique et la
france a maintenant plus on va donner un
répondait abertis après jour et sera
parce que ça qu'un des agents avaient
paniqué la fin répondait d'abord à
battre ici
par exemple mais là à l'oeil mais là
l'idée où l'action c'est pas une action
valider ou non notre position c'est que
monsieur les vues de son propre chef il
m'a contacté et m'a dit voilà damas moi
j'aime bien t t 1 p je regarde ça tous
les jours ainsi mauss et voilà et
lorsqu'il a vu sa tête sont était un
pays à avoir les retours des personnes
qui hélas a prêté qui regardent au
quotidien el hadji adama je sais que tu
connais série où tu connais des
personnes qui travaillent excellent ça
serait bien que je précise mais pourquoi
on expliqué ensuite moi chants patriotes
ceux qui me connaissent je suis très peu
d'exemples du mouvement des gilets
jaunes bien chez moi lorsque mais moi
que j'ai pris connaissance de la vidéo
j'étais choqué avoir une personne se re
des réseaux sociaux
ce dernier de dire une grossièreté tels
que vous venez de relater le second est
choquée nous ont promis les jeunes de
quartiers jeunes de cité car nous
on
dit quoi on y voit là encore ça va nous
stigmatiser nous
devons maintenant lui lorsqu'il a parlé
de la france il parle du stade de france
qu'à ceux qui comprennent pas l'arabe et
10000 à la france
pourrait coûter delphine juste abidal je
vous dise tu retournes vidéo un peu ses
taux avant que ce soit la france trop de
temps
il s'y met
et après ça ils auront bientôt
ces watts des besoins djellil moreau
ça veut dire mais avant ça ça veut dire
à ces gens elle est bel et bien
c'est un peu une icône à la france
alors évidemment il a dit non mais
ensuite nous nous notre génie à la
demande de monsieur biya pour défendre
ses propos ces propos ils sont juste
intolérables
compromis pour que
les revenus si progression tu regrettes
tu regret que ces propos
anormaux j'ai dis pas ça mais si on nous
avait dit ça quoi
que je rentrais le match et tout ce jeu
savamment page et comment je vais
l'aider
et je rentrais sur le match et où il y
avait là deux monde sait ce que je lis
bilal ça par exemple bova ça porte
préjudice à tous qu'on essaie de
défendre et insultes à vis des lois tout
ce qu'on est celle des touareg a lancé
voilà
c'est ça quand le drapeau but l'origine
est une histoire beaucoup de personnes
je vois les pseudos patriotes et ceux
des nationalistes moi j'aime la france
quand tu vas dire des propos sur la
france un touché toutes ces terrains je
dors pas de rouget de lisle genre pas
d'accuser rien à ma prédiction des
discours c'est très beau vous êtes
l'armée après la réalité et la réalité
ces pauvres en france je vais nickel à
français ça c'est ce qu'on voit et ça
c'est ce que vous dites mais je peux
vous venez il ya un super beau discours
patriotique et tout ça mais il traduit
jamais monsieur moi j'essaie juste de
répondre à madrid a rien fait le sénat
mais on a un super bowl histoire à
chaque fois on a deux mois moi c'est
juste de reprendre adaptation de cellcom
serait jamais permis de venir avec un
jeune homme de mon quartier dodoma ville
ou de mon environnement afin de mettre
votre et en pâture des jeans et t mobile
ces matches à damas je m'excuse par
rapport aux propos j'ai pu tenir je
m'excuse se saper au fond c'est nombre
de ceux de citoyens citoyennes
françaises et français je m'excuse je
m'excuse si ça a un impact même par
rapport à mes origines qu'elle est
d'origine algérienne et nombre de
personnes sur les réseaux sociaux l'on a
mutilé de tous les noms il a ensuite
raymond même des menaces de mort
aujourd'hui on sait très bien que les
propos qu'il a tenus par rapport à la
conjoncture qu'on n'a pas rapport la
crise identitaire que l'on que l'on
traverse ça choque moi deux premiers
mois le premier carole longueur de
journée mais selon connaissez pas moi ce
que j'ai fait sur le territoire national
à faire de poids afin de promouvoir une
histoire de la france les murs de la
france est venu tenter d'accroître ce
même pas imaginer avoir largué sur
justement
et s'excuse et après je vais le redire
tel film en moi j'ai une question quand
tu comprends le tu comprends le lynchage
oui j'ai une question très simple pour
bilal alors tu peux me répondre juste
par oui ou par non est ce que tu es fier
de vivre en france ouais d'accord et
donc quand tu es fier donc ce que la
france te donne toi tu me rends en
disant nique la france non j'ai trompé
les revenus pour excuser mais en fait là
dans ce match parce que est ce qu'il y
avait le maroc ou l'algérie qui jouait
non alors pourquoi est-ce que du coup tu
as dû parler du maroc et de l'algérie
d'accord non mais je suis d'accord mais
en fait en france tu dis nique la france
eux puis ensuite tu dis vive d'autres
pays c'était origines mais je veux dire
si tu as choisi la france c'est bien
parce que tu as voulu quitter ton pays
pour venir en france et si tu les aimes
et si tu la respectes comme tu dis tu as
pas droit à dire vivre tu atteindras
dernier que la france voit je suis est
ce que c'est populaire le dire ça est ce
que c'est c'est populaire c'est bien
pour les gens qui t'entourent c'est ça
fait sympa de dire ça mais
sur le corner pourquoi est ce qu'on
entend toujours cette phrase tu as moi
j'ai besoin de comprendre nique la
france genre c'est un peu un slogan
pourquoi est-ce qu'on devait enfin je
vous explique ce jeune homme est un
criminel s'est déclaré ruth vachon
roulé tout le temps sans raison dans les
quartiers nous entende et mutua france
mais je dis pas en clarté je dis juste
cette phrase d'une mante est ce qu'elle
épaule en avons à dire quelque chose
depuis la non c'est pas bien normal
cette phrase je les débats c'est pas
bien j'ai touché toute la france et de
la france près normal moi j'ai pas de
droite ce dessin et pourquoi tu l'as dit
gelé dès ses premiers mois j'ai rentré
stade g savez mes enfants comme lui par
le stade de france était vraiment pas
comment une sortie si tu rentres dans le
stade de france qui dit aviv la france
je suis trop content dit brésil via mais
avant tout
puisque je parle pas arabe donc je
préfère qu'on me dit
minimum on écoute et ma mère
je sais pas quoi dire
même la france à côté de ça tirait sa
force dans le sens pourquoi madame il
parlait du stade de france mettant nous
jeunes de cachets par jour c'est à dire
le stéphanois ilan icon sport le stade
de france de france de temps notamment
étaient dans l'euphorie on ne fait pas
c'est comme un homme on part de la
finale de la ligue des champions sont
grandes ouvertes donc si
vous rentrez dans le stade de france
pour ceux que ça un verre continue
d'ailleurs j'en attends je m'attendais
madame genre jeu je réponds je parte de
france sans ticket ya du respect 6000 à
7000 euros
j'aime la france mais en gros j'ai
réussi à berner le choix d'offrir la
meilleure des santés
il vient avec avec toute limite
je vais mourir je veux dire comment l'on
prie sur les gens qui l'ont vu ils sont
dites j'aime la france parce que je peux
c'est ici c'est un sale à ce que je sais
pas si quelque chose et que je peux
rendre sa défense est fine et la fin
c'est comme ça qu'on veut lui ce scud tu
peux tout donner pour se maintenir que
la france ça veut dire ah bah c'est beau
la france voilà je suis bien en france
basque est en france on est bien
d'accord en france ont aidé nul voila
basée à gilles segris oui c'est vrai que
l'effet des paroles est dévastateur bien
sûr pour nous qui essayons de défendre
les quartiers les choses positives qui
s'y passe merci messieurs c'est vrai que
je trouve que vos excuses vous devriez
l'ailé les reformuler vraiment parce que
honnêtement moi je trouve que le
lynchage que vous subissez c'est
scandaleux je suis de votre côté mais
pour des gens comme nous vous entendre
dire ça ça fout tout en l'air sur donc
il faut que vous retiriez ces paroles et
je pense que si vous aimez vraiment la
france comme vous l'avez dit à défiler
je n'en doute pas dit que vous aimez la
france pour tout ce qu'elle vous apporte
est ce parce que sinon ça mais moi je
vais vous dire vous m'avez fait mal si
nous avait fait mal moi je consomme on a
des milliers en 2000 et des centaines de
milliers de gens sont au trésor vauban
devant brett vous défense
avec les mêmes les réactions liszt ça
mais moi ça me fait mal ça me fait
passer l'âge
parce qu'on ne connaissait pas plus que
ça mais jamais de la vie je me
permettrais de dire je te prendrais
fournit une personne qui a pu insulter
voilà l'essence et l'existence de notre
belle nation qui s'appelle la france
nous nos parents quoi sur une enfance
ont traversé la méditerranée ils ont été
accueillis comme il se nomme adam nos
parents ont été accueillis comme il se
doit ils ont pu travailler ils ont pu
nous éduquer alors je veux pas dire que
la france est aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce
jeune homme la senior qui ne refera plus
car c'est un impact considérable dans
son cercle familial ça n'a pas que
considérable dans son travail mais c'est
normal ne valait même pas l'impact que
ça aujourd'hui lorsqu'il vient et non je
reçois un monsieur qui vient dire voilà
il y est pourquoi je suis là qu'elle n'a
pas cette facilité pour s'exprimer en
français c'est pour ça que cela pour
essayer de deux doses frontières ce
qu'il a pu vivre et ce qui est ce
qu'elle est c'est de dire de cette vidéo
mais ensuite c'est lui je te rejoins
totalement mais même moi vous savez pas
quel point j'aime à france 2 et parfums
du scar mandat m'en direz je tourne un
peu à droite voire d'extrême droite
tellement je fasse de la france est
aujourd'hui c'est pas n'importe quelle
personne qui ces dix jeunes de quartiers
des jeunes de cités par rapport au
cinéma qu'on peut nous donner va revenir
avec le drapeau bleu-blanc-rouge
pourquoi moi je le fais pas pour moi je
mets pour tous les jeunes banlieusards
la toux les personnes qui habitent dans
les quartiers mais près de 11 millions
d'habitants on en a marre d'avoir cette
étiquette d'abord ce genre de vidéos
bien sûr ça donne une mauvaise image des
quartiers de cité mais moi c'est bilal
qui m'appelle séparé que ton frère ne
parle plus depuis tes propos ouais et
parle pas avec moi il faut peu de mal et
bien sûr donc même grande famille tu as
bien sûr et à tes propos ils ont été
choqués il faut il les cautionne pas
donc vers ton frère et parle plus parler
tu as dit quoi et habitat marcel à des
normes on nous tue mais pas un gros mot
comme ça dans la vie du tout la france
je vais vie c est tout gdj trempé
jusqu'ici tu travailles jamais je
travaille jamais jamais
une histoire jamais on parle d'un coup
je travaille à côté d'un city et tout
jamais
daniel en fait moi ce qui me gêne c'est
y est vous ça y est le langage verbal il
ya ce qu'on dit et puis il ya le langage
non verbal est ce qu'on peut revoir la
photo d'aveyron avec votre camarade
parce que ce que je veux bien entendre
tout ce que vous dites sur ce que vous
avez voulu dire pas dit et tout ça il
les a regardé cette photo est ce que
vous pensez que ça serve votre cause
fort qu'il n'en est pas une mais est-ce
que vous pensez que ça sert les gens de
banlieue qui sont quand même évidemment
beaucoup si matinée mais là les légendes
du rn ils doivent se frotter les mains
regarder cette image s'est désolé moi je
ne fais je vous fais pas un mauvais
procès vous avez compté pour vous est
peut-être mal exprimé sur ce que vous
avez dit je pourrais éventuellement
entendre ses excuses là mais je suis
désolé cette image elle fait énormément
de demandes au mal et ça vous pouvez
m'expliquer ce que vous voulez on semble
n vous devriez être content à la rigueur
un peu gamin en disant ah ouais j'ai
profité je suis passé c'est super et je
vais voir un match mais ça je suis
désolé vous mais vous ne me convaincrez
pas sur ces images dans le langage non
verbal et la nuit beaucoup de madame la
venue d'un petit jeune café un dérapage
drame au check-in en france et touche
combien de temps comment ces centaines
de sympathisants de plus de 16 ans
j'habite problème bien bien acérées il
travaille reconnu pour son
professionnalisme des farines qui
démonte pas inquiet surtout maintenant
que cette photo c'est pas trop tôt mais
s'inscrit non
malgré tout nous alors peut-être je me
trompe je ressens de la haine je me sens
quelque part c'est madame madame dans la
rue demain jour de la finale de la
libérer oui mais bref conte macabre est
justement
jouer moi j'ai moi j'ai dit oui ça fait
beaucoup de mal ça fait beaucoup de
mariages et aux jeunes on a fait
beaucoup de mal à ceux qui veulent s'en
sortir sur beaucoup de mal à ceux qui
veulent aller chercher du travail on va
leur dire vous venez d'où la seine saint
denis et c'est cela qui vont se faire
plomber un sur une alerte a dit on est
très content parce qu'il a berné stade
de france non tu ne m'aimes ça tu dois
ne pas le dire tu dois pas dire il a
berné le stade de france parce qu'il ya
des gens qui ont grillé explique matthew
nantes a dit l'arrêt c'est bien un jeune
il a un côté il est rentré la
même manière qu à moi je veux bien qu'on
me dise que c'est les anglais où ils ont
une part de responsabilité peut-être
avec les faux bien mais c'est pas les
anglais consotel agri les gens sont soit
il a présenté la grille mais je lis les
gens font sauter la grille tous ces gens
là font marche arrière ton fait marche
arrière par rapport à ce qu'on essaye
nous de faire un jeu faire passer comme
message ici de dire que c'est pas parce
que tu viens de syndic n'étais pas doué
c'est pas parce que t'as pas fait
d'études que t'es pas doué on peut
donner des chances avec des discours
comme ça un patron d'entreprise il va
dire il vole longtemps dire nique la
france et l'autre derrière qui fait ses
trucs de pistolet 10 m à ces mecs là
j'en veux pas j'en veux pas c'est ça le
tort qu'il fait mais c'est pourquoi je
dis le chasser saddam
il a gagné la même chose d'accord mais
on peut pas le cautionnement pour autant
de tapage et il a dit exactement la même
chose il faut le dire il faut des nerfs
on a berné le stade
avancé maintenant important je voulais
que tu fais car à la fois dans l'émotion
je peux peut-être je la vends mes mots à
aucun moment je ne pourrait tolérer ne
cautionne pas fait mais maintenant je
pourrais tolérer ou adoubé à
comportements déviants qui ne respectent
pas voilà la menace est bien en amoureux
du droit est aujourd'hui six mois par
rapport à mon principe quand j'étais un
gros délinquants oubliez pas mentir
c'est vraiment dg plus de conscience il
me suis je me suis je me suis actionnée
dans tous les aspects social au
contraire et bien c'est pour des
dépenses et à des petits pères et le
premier conseil que je veux leur donner
attention avec les stars car au final
les fnac mais m as-tu-vu les réseaux
sociaux enfin en train de débuter ces
gens là alors que tu es juste s'il vous
plaît
gounon mais il a dit une connerie mais
ça me choque qu'on lynche publiquement
un jeune qui a mis nos souris sur snap
chadourne personnalité publique disent
des conneries il y en a plein un jeune
qui fait un signe de pistolets ça veut
pas dire je vais tirer ce jour là c'est
un jeune d'origine maghrébine donc ça
veut dire je vais tirer surtout merci à
la malbaie semblant mais pas loin mais
ne semble en rien à plein des jeunes
c'est très bien épaulé
il ya des menaces de mort et regarder
les tweeds sert ya trop d'argent pour un
centrisme c'est dégueulasse donc stop au
zaman fait une connerie ses excuses et
arrêtez arrêtez de les chausser
prétentieux je suis quand même chose
c'est de dire il ya nadine king c'est
pas très grave mais c'est pas parce qu'à
notre d'autres cas contraire on veut
tout faire et ses pattes c'est le
problème c'est pas des erreurs c'est pas
parce que d'autres qui font des
conneries que quand nous on en revanche
aucune connaît faut rien dire du tout
destiné mais quand quelqu'un autre camp
justice juste retour des choses les
menaces de mort
c'est la merde s'il vous plaît juste
bilal je vais te laisser le mot de la
fin est ce que tu veux dire quelque
chose même à ton frère aulas qui peut te
regardent peut-être où tous les atouts
les français qui n'ont rien qui ont été
choquées et voilà et qu'est ce que tu
aurais quelque chose à leur dire ce soir
j'ai des excuse tout le monde j'ai pas
fait exprès non non j'ai fais pas ça ce
qu'est ce que c'est pas appris à ton
frère tu lui dirais quoi qui veut pas de
parler mon frère ça fait une semaine ils
veulent pas me parler avec moi
il a fait une connerie que tu tues tu te
rends compte de deux voilà parce qu'en
fait c'est le symbole que tu as que tu
as envoyé ces six-là pas et me l'a pas
aimé que j'ai mis cette vidéo il a
d'énormes en mode super tu veux pas
s'agiter s'est pas fait attention j
seront très beau feu lui même mon pote
koné fissa et ça vraiment pas ajouté je
filme et regarde match d'un coup
liverpool d'un coup moi je filme louis
et savait mapaero garde et philippe ça
c'est tout il savait mans par jour fine
je ne fume pas et rien du tout
après mon beau-frère et l'appeler ma
mère et où il n'a pas dit et vous
l'epadesa notre mer était beaucoup et
voulait pas des jv saïto sazy surveiller
longtemps j'ai pas vu mon mari tout et
vous savez des vous travaillez vous avez
dit vous êtes au travail coiffeur et
c'est vrai patron donc je travaillais
avec quelqu'un d'accord d'accord travers
mais là vous avez l'air comme un boxeur
ko est ce que vous êtes malheureux de
tout ce que vous avez fait de tout ce
que vous avez dit est-ce que vous ce que
vous ressentez dans votre coeur est-ce
que c'est du malheur pourrais je sentais
venir ce sont
donc ces malheureux d'avoir fait ça de
dingue je sentais de ouf ça veut dire
comores mois neutre et surtout moi ils
sont mon père y sont et où j'ai senti